the pandemic happened obviously
kind of switched up everyone's take like
i think uh andrew scholes kind of showed
people like a way of like doing comedy a
whole different way and still kind of
keeping your integrity bro yeah he's
he's the moses right now that [ __ ] he's
leading us it's like all right that's
how you that's how you get down and it's
not corny you know that's what i'm
saying
you know what i mean it's not
it's not shots fired yeah
it's not jonas brothers my space [ __ ]
it's like it's not like uh it's like oh
that's how you do it i'm with that it's
like mixtape [ __ ] it's like he's passing
out mixtapes out of his trunk but on the
internet you know it's like it's hip-hop
it's punk rock i'm like you get down
with schultz because of that and he's
not afraid to say [ __ ] that's facts um
but like for you personally how have you
kind of like
uh
has it like like the last year and some
change has it kind of made you look at
things differently or pivot in a certain
way [ __ ] yes
because all this has done is it
separated
fake you know it separates the uh the
fake from the from the real ones like
you really get to see who your real ones
are you know what i mean like i'm
assuming everyone's circle got smaller
because obviously because of covered but
then you're like you really got to see
everybody's character you know like
especially when it came back outside it
was like oh you [ __ ] didn't really
give a [ __ ] you were just saying it for
the clout